hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the round 2 of sham clear
chess tournament the the vulgar Shima
Memorial Tournament ice again between
world champion Magnus Carlsen and former
world champion Viswanathan Anand
even though just finished a lot of
behold already requested it and it's
it's quite a lovely game so I thought
okay why not show it I decided not show
any games from round 1 of the regime of
Memorial as round 1 was well fairly
uneventful round 2 seems to be a lot of
our work is going on and before we check
out the game if you're interested last
year before the ashram kitchen's
tournament I I made one video in honor
and memory of huger Shima so I will put
a link to it in the description below if
you're interested in checking that out
so it's a very interesting game like I
said it's a 10 player single round-robin
the players are fighting for a hundred
thousand euros first place is 30,000
euros it's a bit of a different it's not
19 minute 90 minutes per player plus
more time when they reach time control
it's actually 120 minutes for the first
40 moves then additional hour after they
reach move 40 and of course 30 seconds
per increment for starting from move 1
and if there will be a tie at the end of
the tournament at the players will will
go in a rapid playoff so something
well pretty much all of them will enjoy
but yeah and getting back to this game I
said it will be interesting because well
Allen employs a defense Caruana used
against Carlsen in in in their game 2 of
their World Chess Championship match in
London year last year so let's check it
out with d4 Knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight to
f3 and here d5 we go into the Queens
gambit declined nice to see Knight to
the c3 Bishop to e7
something off Bishop to f4
Anand castles that we have III c5
everything the same as in round 2 of
course and vs Caruana match in London D
captures Bishop captures we have Queen
to c2 and now Knight to c6 we have a
three Queen to a5 we already explained
everything
in our video cousin versus Caruana about
why before doesn't it doesn't go here
and things like that we have looked at
the one by white rook to d8 by Anand and
now comes the Bishop to e2 and here nice
to e4 and here I will put a second link
in the description below it will be if
you haven't seen it my video on the game
Carlson vs. Caruana from the role Chess
Championship match where we've discussed
this position in detail and all the
moves
prior to this position so if you're
interested in that to do check it out in
this game it's actually Carlsen hearts
sake if Coulson thought that Anand would
employ the same defenses Caruana but
it's actually Carlson who deviates here
in their game to cross and went castles
in that game of course ended in a draw I
was a very very feisty draw but here
it's Costin who deviates with C captures
on d5 and C characters on d5 is a new
move has not been played before or since
or after the head across on vs. Caruana
game so it's now as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game on our hands
okay first Anand captures the knight
Knight captures with B captures and he
captures on d5 now Carson castles and
here you can't go for the a3 pond by the
Queen or by the better if you capture
then route k1 I just traps the better of
whatever you play next Queen b3 is
coming in the bishop is trapped you're
gonna lose a piece here so Anand just
creates a bit of a breathing room for
for his King we have a four by Carlsen
that pawn will no longer be a target in
the future and also it already prevents
expansion on the Queen side by Anand
with Bishop to d6 Anand once the trade
of the dark square Bishop switch goes
well across and doesn't mind because it
allows him to get not to get rid of his
weak c3 pawn but to make it a strength
rather than a weakness so across an
exchange the special captures rook
captures and now pushes c4 so the
isolated backwards pawn is no longer a
problem
you cannot capture as the rook on d6 is
undefended we have Bishop to e6
now defending the pawn and here Carlson
is not interested in in an equalist
position
which would happen if he captures a
writer he goes c5 he stifles Aaron's
development on the queenside and he
wants to now create some pressure along
the B file with his rooks rookie d back
to d8 by Anand nakum's rook to be one
going after the b7 pawn which is now a
backwards pawn and here you can go b6
because if b6 pawn captures your knight
on c6 is unguarded you don't have time
to recapture so here on goes Queen back
to c7 we have Queen to be two with a
double attack against the b7 pawn and on
on defense at rook a to be eight and out
Knights the d4 attacking the bishop
attacking the knight with ideas of going
to be five wooden an attack on the Queen
and also on the h7 pawn so definitely
almost a monster night but definitely a
very nice night so uh none decides to
remove it Knight captures and now not
pawn captures because then b6 would open
up the file for the rook and your Queen
occupies the same file so here cross and
first captures with the Queen we have
Queen captures on d4 and only now be 6
by aren't see capture some basics we
have rook captures and b6 and now comes
h3 creating some breathing room for the
king and and also preparing maybe the g4
square for the light square bishop we
have looked the c8 by island out at the
grabbing hold of the C file rook F to D
1 by Carlsen and now Queen the c3 Island
offers a trade of Queens and cross and
goes for it we have Queen captures on c3
rook captures on c3 and now a5 push King
the point even further the bishop on e -
very nicely controls this diagonal so
the pawn can be safely pushed to a6
we have rook captures on b1 first rope
capture some b1 and this is already we
could say a very important position in
the game also could be a critical
position in the game here what
Anand needs to do is play g5 and just
wait for call center to do a rook lift
for example rook to b7 and then he will
go rook the c1 give a check go back rook
to c2 pressure the bishop after the
bishop moves you can capture an f2 and
so on but here sorry now that a here
under makes a move that is a
well that wastes precious time he plays
rook the c5 with an attack against the
f5 pawn and here our cousin just pushes
it to a six so the more Luke c5 didn't
really do anything but it's hard to see
the consequent consequences that rook to
see if I will have unless you see the
rest of the game which you will here we
have g6 another possible idea was Bishop
to c8 for Anand which is an ugly move
yes you go after the ACE exponent you
allow Carlsen to pin your Bishop good
ideas of Bishop to g4 entrapping it but
you can go g6 next and now you will be
able to take care of any bishop ideas
with with the move f5 so this is the one
option although not not the the most
active one I don't went for a different
plan he played g6 first now comes looked
to be 7 by Carlson and now Anand tries
the same idea that we already discussed
which the difference that he lost one
move when he played rook to c5 he now
goes rook to c1 check King to h2
rook to c2 attacks the bishop bishop has
to move like we already mentioned and
now he could go for rook captures rook
captures but well he's just a bit slower
now he first goes rook to be 2 now not
allowing Carlsen to capture an a7 as the
bishop and b5 is under attack
we have kinked the g3 by Carlsen now
defending the f2 pawn and now Bishop the
c8 and here you will see the problem
Carlson of course goes rook to b8 the
only the only move and now he pins the
bishop here and here if you can imagine
if Ireland did not waste that rook to
see if I move if he immediately moved
the Jeep on then his king could already
be on g7 and you know there would
already be ideas like Bishop captures on
a6 as you know the bishop would not be
thinned here Anand has to waste a move
now with King to g7 and now cousin is uh
well he's free to trade and go into a
rooks end game he plays rook captures on
c8 with rook captures on b5 and now rook
to c7 Carlson is now faster in grabbing
the a7 pawn and there's no way to stop
it with Luke a5 rook captures an a7 not
cross and is up a pawn and it's already
a passed pawn on a6 we have king to f6
now comes rook to e8
to pull the point all the way to a seven
rook to a3 and now comes King back to h2
you don't want to allow this bush and
allow this pin so first King to h2 now
comes h5 by Anand and now a seven and
notice that the the black king of course
cannot allow any move that will allow
the white rook sorry about that
the white rook to deliver check now
because if you do something like this
then it's check and well white will get
a queen into the game so Anand
constantly has to keep an eye on his
King and not allow any checks here he
goes Luke 2:8 two attacks DF to pawn but
there's never really any threat of
capturing it because white simply moves
the rook and promotes the point into a
queen
we have h4 by Carlsen with King to f5
and now f3 here aren't played rook to a
1 and after g3 it was in this position
that Vishwanathan Anand resigned to the
game and a very nice victory for Magnus
Carlsen who who is already closed in
live ratings 228 50 which means he's
well improved his rating quite a bit as
he was dropping for a very long time and
he's not he's not all the way back to
his former glory but he's definitely
improving
quite a lot so it's interesting why did
he resign well because black has no
useful moves black can just wait for
white to take the king of the board for
example even if you just continue
checking your rook check check check
then the King will just go g1 for
example F 2 e 1 D 3 you can go D 1 C 2 B
b3 b4 here and then at some point the
rook will have to decide whether the
rook will guard the d5 pawn or you will
capture the d5 pawn and then you will
just be up to pawns and well that will
be even more easily winning or you will
defend the d5 point and then white will
simply move the rook and promote the a
point to a queen this is the simplest
explanation of how how it wins but yeah
and of course was not interested as its
it's a textbook endgame so there's
there's no point both of them know that
this is completely winning for white
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it we're not gonna be showing
the standings or anything as it's only
round 2 and by the looks of it it's a
very eventful round
so you know probably will be showing
some more games and other than that's
roped the c5 move that Alan played which
was seemingly a waste of time here that
rook to c5 it doesn't seem that there
was any mistake played in this game this
is just yeah he gave Carlsen one extra
move course and used it and after that
it was it was just pushing a slightly
better positioning into a win chef now
once again that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it do check out the links in the
description below if you're interested a
video I made in honor and memory of
Google Shima with the second link will
be Carano vs. cousin if you're
interested in this line as its discussed
a lot more in their Watchers
championship game and also I will
include the trailer to do rank HS
classic and the fourth link maybe maybe
the ad the video our team or grave jumps
out of an airplane with with the
chessboard if you still haven't seen it
and do check it out it's it's quite mean
it's quite lovely
yeah I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank George C Georgia the organ
brain Schmidt Marcus David Allen ferns
and Michael Hildebrand for contributing
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content just you know doing what we
usually do here and I I have to stress
this out we are getting back to the
couple Monica saga but we if there's a
you know a nice event going on and
there's a nice game we don't have to
cover that as well the sagas are not
going anywhere there are there you know
for for the rest of the history so yeah
thank you all and I will see you soon
have an excellent rest of your day